[Musique]
merci Jean-Michel Arnaud de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu des Hautes
Alpes mem du groupe Union centriste et
vous êtes agriculteur on va évidemment
parler de cette crise agricole dans
quelques instant mais d'abord on l'a vu
dans le journal François Baayou a donc
été relaxé hier au bénéfice du doute
dans l'affaire des assistants
parlementaires du MoDem est-ce que vous
souhaitez son retour au gouvernement je
crois d'abord que il esttait important
que la justice passe comme toujours dans
ce genre d'affaires et euh dans
l'affaire Barou modem UDF comme souvent
dans les affaires concernant nos
concitoyens le temps la justice est long
trop long c'est temps pour juger une
affaire qu'on soit citoyen ou qu'on soit
responsable politique économique c'est
trop long maintenant François Baayou est
le courant qu'il incarne est un courant
important dans la vie politique
française et il est me semble
intéressant d'imaginer qu'au sein du
futur gouvernement on a un réquilibrage
au centre parce que pour qu'une majorité
fonctionne il faut qu'elle soit
équilibrée sur ces deux jambes une jambe
un peu plus à droite avec une
demi-douzaine de ministres aujourd'hui
qui viennent deslrin qui ont été LR dans
le passéop c'est trop j'en sais rien
dans tous les cas c'est ainsi et il est
important qu'il y ait également un
pilier beaucoup plus centriste et de
centre gauche aussi donc je crois que
c'est l'enjeu au-delà de cet embouille
finalement politique ce qui est
important c'est que sur un certain
nombre de sujets on va certainement
parler l'agriculture l'éducation on a
des réponses fortes aux demandes de nos
concitoyens qui sont importantes et
qu'on résorbe un peu le fossé qui
s'accroit fortement entre les
responsables et les citoyens avec comme
conséquence et comme finalement résultat
la montée des populismes de toutes
sortes ça passe par quoi ce
rééquilibrage au centre est-ce qu'il
faut plus de modem est-ce qu'il faut des
udi des sénateurs udi dans ce
gouvernement ce que je crois c'est qu'il
faut qu'il y ait des sénateurs euh parce
que je ne comprendrai pas alors que euh
il y a dans les
territoires un espace de confiance créé
entre les élus locaux et les citoyens
que la transition écologique se fera
dans les territoires euh que nous avons
besoin aussi euh d'élus euh qui
connaissent les territoires et qui à
côté des élus locaux connaî le mieux les
territoires le sénateur et donc je crois
qu'il est important que la Haute
Assemblée puisse dans sa diversité hein
parce que il y a le choix on a tout tout
l'arc politique représenté au Sénat
puisse montrer à travers son expérience
sa connaissance des territoires la voix
que le gouvernement doit emprunter pour
résoudre les problèmes des Français sauf
que les sénateurs centristes aujourd'hui
il sont alliés au LR ici au Sénat donc
dans une opposition constructive comme
comme le disent Gérard Larché RV
Marseille est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il y a des sénateurs de votre groupe
qui rentre au gouvernement et est-ce que
ça marquerait une rupture avec la
majorité sénatoriale dans tous les cas
la majorité sénatoriale repose sur
d'autres fondamentaux que les clivages
politiques classiques euh je rappelle
que au sein de du groupe Union centriste
nous avons des élus du MoDem des élus de
l'IDI et puis des personnes comme moi
qui sont sans un tâche partisane mais
qui épousent euh cette volonté à la fois
de liberté et d'originalité qu'incarne
le groupe Union centriste et si un de
mes collègues au groupe unioncentriste
entrait au gouvernement euh ça serait
probablement un signe surtout de
reconnaissance de leur engagement
territoriaux plus que un bouleversement
de la majorité sénatoriale parce que je
crois que il n'y a pas de débat
aujourd'hui au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale dans le soutien porortter à
la manière dont Gérard Larcher exerce sa
présidence pour tous les sénateurs où
qu'il se situent dans l'émicic vous
savez si certains ont été approchés
certains collèg rien on va passer à la
crise agricole je le disais vous êtes
agriculteur est-ce que Gabriel Atal a
bien géré cette crise selon vous est-ce
que le mouvement est éteint aujourd'hui
d'abord ce que je pense pouvoir devoir
dire c'est que ce ce ce mouvement et
cette colère vient de loin être paysan
c'est incarner son pays c'est avoir une
capacité non seulement à à façonner les
les paysages mais aussi et surtout à
nourrir les hommes et donc le fait que
la population agricole finalement à
travers sa détresse exprime finalement
une recherche de dignité est important
après au-delà des questions de la
défiscalisation du génère de
l'accélération ou ou ou de de
l'atténuationtion de la problématique
liée au phytosanitaire et la transition
écologique je crois que c'est cette
recherche de dignité qui est importante
et puis on dit souvent les agriculteurs
sont aussi des chefs d'entreprise enfin
je tiens à dire et c'est probablement là
aussi un élément majeur et qui faitcho
aux aux appétences aux attentions aux
volontés de la population française de
manière général que d'avoir une
revalorisation de son pouvoir d'achat
c'est quand même la seule profession que
je connaisse qui ne fixe jamais son prix
auprès de son acheteur et ça c'est un
vrai sujet et si j'avais finalement une
recommandation à formuler et un message
à faire passer au gouvernement et
notamment à la grande distribution c'est
la clarté du prix on va en parler on va
en parler de la grande distribution avec
la la presse régionale c'est Léo purgade
de la marseillaèe qui sera avec nous
dans quelques instants mais loi Galim et
et grande distribution mis à part est-ce
que les annonces ont été les bonnes
est-ce que il fallait mettre en pause le
plan écofito par exemple ce que je crois
c'est que quand je vous le disais crise
et la colère des agriculteurs vient de
loin parce que on est tous reliés à la
terre on est tous reliés au monde
agricole et finalement c'est de là d'où
on vient tous tous les Français viennent
de la terre et donc quand on a en
quelques mois en quelques années
l'obligation d'une transition
forceé rapide trop rapide il est normal
que ça craque et donc ne pas remettre en
cause les objectifs de
décarbonation de de lever de du poids
des pesticides
je crois que c'est partagé par la grande
partie la grande majorité des
agriculteurs qui sont d'ailleurs les
premiers à être confrontés au risque de
santé lié à l'usage de ces
phytosanitaires maintenant il est
important d'abord un que les
agriculteurs comprennent les raisons
pour lesquelles on est obligé d'aller
dans ce sens-là donc il faut de la
pédagogie il faut également faire
confiance à la science pour accompagner
les agriculteurs techniquement dans leur
mutation dans les modalités de
production et faire en sorte voilà de de
les réorienter prressivement vers
d'autres pratiques agricoles et puis
donner un peu de temps pour que
économiquement ça suive et donc faire en
sorte que en quelques mois en quelques
années on demande une révolution
agricole une révolution technique à des
agriculteurs qui font déjà beaucoup
d'efforts c'est évidemment très
compliqué pour eux donc je ne sais pas
s'il faut remettre en cause probablement
pas cette orientation parce que c'est
nécessaire pour l'avenir de l'humanité
mais je pense qu'il est nécessaire de
faire une pause de
poser l'ensemble des éléments du débat
et coconstruire avec les agriculteurs
une nouvelle feuille de route on va
parler justement de la grande
distribution et des galimes qui était
évidemment l'un des POS importants de
cette colère des agriculteurs je le
disais pour en parler on va aller à
Marseille on retrouve Léo purgade
bonjour Léo merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous président et directeur éditoriel du
journal La Marseillaise Léo le mouvement
des agriculteurs continue chez vous avec
certaines actions coup de point dirigé
contre la grande
distribution tout à fait elles sont
l'œuvre de la Confédération paysane ou
euh de la coordination rurale qui se
disent insatisfait de l'accord trouvé
avec la FNSEA et et le gouvernement euh
ce qu'il pointe et bien c'est la
question de la rémunération du travail
agricole qui bien sûr est un peu la
grande absence de cet accord avec le
gouvernement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il cible des plateformes
logistiques de la grande distribution en
exigeant d'avoir des
avancées sur ce sujet alors je vous
voulaz euh interroger euh euh monsieur
le sénateur savoir s'il était favorable
à la mise en place de coefficient
multiplicateurs hein pour permettre euh
et bien de contraindre les marges de la
grande distribution et euh de relever
les prix d'achat pour les euh les
producteurs c'est une proposition qui
est portée donc par certains syndicats
agricoles mais aussi euh par la gauche
qu'en pensent-t-il euh le journaliste
évoque un sujet essentiel euh c'est la
rémunération des agriculteurs je le
disais à l'instant c'est une des rares
professions où finalement on produit
sans connaître véritablement le le prix
d'achat de ses clients et euh est-ce que
c'est Léo oui non pardonnez-moi euh et
donc il est important d'avoir un la
transparence moi je serais favorable à
ce que les distributeurs quel qu'ils
soit affiche le prix d'achat primaire
auprès de l'agriculteur de la denrée du
produit agricole qui est à la vente euh
pour cela il faut euh effectivement
détricoter la chaîne de valeur euh
souvent j'ai entendu Michel Édouard
Leclerc hier sortant en fin de son
silence expliquer finalement c'est pas
la grande distribution qui prend le plus
de la marge il y a des intermédiaires
chiche allez mettons sur la table euh
quel est le coût euh des intermédiaires
et quel est le prix payé aux agriculteur
ensuite une fois qu'on aurait défini le
prix de production avoir effectivement
un coefficient multiplicateur pour
consolider euh et avoir une parfaite
transparence sur les marges et la chaîne
de valeur moi objectivement c'est une
aentation euh euh utile et nécessaire
euh pour la transparence et euh la
vérité des prix que l'on doit euh au
consommateurs enfin euh nous nous
sous-estimons pas non plus on n'est pas
dans un cercle fermé à l'intérieur des
frontières françaises on est dans un
marché euh européen avec des
financements qui viennent notamment
apporter un revenu aux agriculteurs à
travers la la politique agricole commune
donc nous devons également avoir un
débat qui s'ouvre au sein de l'Union
européenne ça tombe bien il y a des
élections qui arrive dans quelques mois
je pense qu'il va falloir au-delà de la
crise qui semble s'apaiser ouvrir un
débat pour remettre finalement
l'agriculture la capacité de produire en
Europe et donc en France au milieu des
paysages au milieu du villages et au
milieu de la ville alors il y a deux
choses dans ce que vous dites un sur les
revenus Emmanuel Macron il était à
Bruxelles ENIT fin de semaine dernière
il a appelé ses partenaires à un
égalisme Européen justement pour que les
règles soient les mêmes dans tous les
pays d'Europe et pour éviter que la
grande distribution est des centrales
d'achat dans d'autres pays que la France
est-ce que ça c'est la bonne voie dans
tous les cas la bonne voie c'est de
discuter avec ses partenaires euh c'est
discuter mais pas simplement lorsqu'on a
une crise discuter de manière
prospective c'estàd qu'il faut un peu
comme les agriculteurs savent faire il
faut réintroduire le temps long et on ne
gère pas les crises en fonction du
dernier tweet ou en fonction du dernier
coup politique je pense qu' c'est un peu
ça quand même je la colère des des
agriculteurs il n'y a que ceux qui ne
vivent pas dans les campagnes qui n'ont
pas vu venir je le disais ça ça remonte
de loin parce que ces agriculteurs ont
quand même eu depuis 30 à 40 ans à à
faire des révolutions en matière de
production on a finalement une
agriculture paysane qui a quasiment
disparu on est sur une agriculture hélas
de plus en plus industrielle qui permet
certes de prendre des des part de marché
à l'extérieur de l'Union européenne ou
au sein de l'Union mais qui ne garantit
pas un minimum à vivre aux agriculteurs
qui reste dans des modèles plus paysans
plus familiaux et je crois que doivent
cohabiter ces agricultures dans le
territoire national parce que
l'agriculture de montagne dans mon
département les Hautes Alpes n'est pas
tout à fait la même que l'agriculture
dans la région île-de-fance et on n' pas
tout à fait les mêmes marchés mais par
contre il faut que les agriculteurs
notamment des zones de montagne des
zones les plus rurales puissent être
simplement dignement respecté par une
rémunération liée à leur coût de
production pour qu'ils puissent vivre
avec leur famille et continuer aussi à
desservir une agriculture et des
produits sains de qualité dans la
proximité sur des circuits courts Léo
vous avez une autre question et oui vous
évoquer la question européenne un des
grands débats va être l'élargissement ou
pas à l'Ukraine à la Moldavie est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à cet élargissement
sachant que beaucoup d'agriculteurs mais
aussi de salariés hein redoutent une une
concurrence accrue un dumping social et
et fiscal vous savez dans votre question
il il y a deux aspects il y a l'aspect
immédiat lié à la crise agricole et
alimentaire évidemment je peux
comprendre que les agriculteurs français
les agriculteurs européens de l'actuelle
Union européenne puisse être inquiet à
l'idée de voir une des plus grandes
puissances européennes agricoes
l'Ukraine entrer dans l'Union européenne
ceci étant dit le processus est long et
avant d'arriver à cette
perspective vous aurez du temps long là
aussi toujours du temps long et des
transitions des adaptations et puis il y
a l'autre côté de votre question qui est
aussi la question de la défense de
l'Union européenne face à euh au
terrorisme d'État et à la dictature de
Poutine est-ce que l'Union européenne
peut laisser des pays comme la Moldavie
et l'Ukraine seul absorbé par
l'hégémonie russe ma réponse est
clairement non donc il faut leur donner
des perspectives politique et parmi les
perspectives entre autres perspectives
il y a la perspective d'une entrée dans
l'Union européenne mais qui sera longue
et qui nécessitera des transitions comme
C l' avait été fait d'ailleurs dans le
passé lorsque nous avions eu premier
élargissement en 1986 vers les pays du
Sud pour Espagne et Grèce en
particulier merci Léo on dit un mot de
votre une Léo débrayage des docers de
Marseille à fosse plus rien nentre ni ne
sort
oui un mouvement social qui là est
effectivement sur les ports avec des
revendications qui sont double d'abord
et bien élargir l'ambition de Marseille
en grand qui est le plan du président de
la République jusque à Fos qui fait
pleinement partie du port de de
Marseille et puis ensuite des
revendications national qui sont partagé
par les autres docers et portuaires de
tout le pays merci Léo merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
pour nous parler de ces actions qui
continuent dans votre région merci
beaucoup Léo purgette on va parler d'un
autre sujet que vous suivez c'est la
question des loups Gabriel Atal a
annoncé jeudi quand il a fait ses
annonces aux agriculteurs que le plan
loup serait détaillé dans les prochains
jours le plan lou 2024- 20029 qu'est-ce
que vous en attendez j'attends d'abord
que soit mis en œuvre une autre annonce
du gouvernement en l'occurrence celle de
du ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fenau
qui a annoncé une perspective de
déclassement du loup en espèce très
protégé à protéger d'abord dans un
premier temps dans le cadre de la
Directive Habitat européenne donc là
c'est une majorité simple au sein de
l'Union nécessaire pour pouvoir obtenir
ce déclassement et puis ensuite deuxième
perspective plus compliqué puisque c'est
à l'unanimité et ce n'est pas au sein de
l'Union européenne c'est dans le casre
de la Convention de Berne donc c'est un
traité international avoir égal éalement
le même process jusqu'est-ce que ça
changerait de passer d'espèce très
protégé à espèces protégé d'abord c'est
une reconnaissance et c'est important
symbolique et forte que le loup n'est
plus une espèce en danger imminent de
disparition puisque déclassé dans la
nomenclature la classification du loup
démontre que le loup a progressé il
suffit de regarder tous les territoires
de France pratiquement y compris bientôt
dans la dans la forêt de Fontainebleau
ou dans le bois de Boulogne on aura des
loups donc on en a partout donc je crois
que c'est important d'avoir déjà cette
dimension symbolique et deux il faudra
effectivement si céit si c'était le cas
qu'on en ait des conséquences sur le
plan loup national avec de mon point de
vue deux orientations nécessaires un
faire en sorte de donner plus la main au
préfet de département comme dans
beaucoup d'autres politiques d'ailleurs
nécessaire pour pouvoir mieux juger le
niveau de quôas de prélèvement à l'année
et faire en sorte que les autorisations
soient plus fluides territorialisé
c'està-dire il faut que ce soit
territoire pas territoire il faut pas
que ce soit national exactement on peut
avoir un un PR prélèvement global
national mais avoir plus de souplesse
dans l'intervention locale deuxièmement
donner plus de pouvoir d'agir au
louvtiers avec des moyens matériels plus
ciblés avec des lunettes spécialisées
pour le tir de nuit par exemple et puis
faire en sorte également de travailler
sur l'autodéfense aussi des agriculteurs
ouiséis comme ça et ENF il me semble
donc ça veut dire juste pardon que
n'importe quel éleveur même s'il n'a pas
le permis de chasse il est menacé par un
loup il doit avoir l'autorisation de
c'est comme ça que je vois le sujet pour
là aussi rétablir un peu de confiance et
aussi dignité dans le travail des
éleveurs qui sont confrontés à beaucoup
de souffrance avec leur famille
confronté au loup et puis le dernier
point c'est travailler aussi sur un des
éléments de protection qui est qui est
le chien de protection et faire en sorte
que le chien de protection est une là
aussi une classification qui ne soit pas
simplement un chien de un chien rant
mais un chien concourrant à l'exercice
d'une profession et que dans des
conditions d'attaque de ces loups sur
des tiers parce que on a quand même une
monté en puissance de ce genre de
situation la recherche de responsabilité
de l'éleveur soit amoindrie pour faire
en sorte également là aussi d'apaiser
psychologiquement les agriculteurs et
puis le dernier point c'est évidemment
maintenir un un niveau de nité qui
permettent de de combler les pertes pour
les agriculteurs confrontter notamment
les éleveurs comme les autres à des
problématiques de revenus
particulièrement forte en zone de
montagne et en zone très rural allons
suivre évidemment le détail de ce plan
lou annoncé dans les prochains jours on
termine par l'actualité du Sénat et on
reparle de la loi immigration censurée
en grande partie par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais les sénateurs
centristes ont décidé de reprendre la
quasi totalité de ces mesures censuré
d'en faire une proposition de loi on
voie le détail avec Alex
poussa
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour ran bonjour
JeanMichel Jean-Michel Arnaud bonjour et
Alex les sénateur centriste propose donc
de réintroduire les mesures de la loi
immigration qui ont été retoquées par le
Conseil constitutionnel et oui il y a 10
jours le Conseil constitutionnelle avait
censuré 40 % de la loi immigration et
notamment des mesures qui avaient été
rajoutées dans le texte par les
sénateurs de droite et du centre et ces
mesures elles ont été censurées non pas
sur le fond mais sur la forme car elles
n'avaient pas un lien direct avec le
sujet du projet de loi immigration
initiale de géralde d'armanin et donc
les sénateurs centristes ont déposé une
proposition de loi pour réintroduire
certaines de ces mesures retoqué
notamment le durcissement des règles du
regroupement familial le délis de séjour
irrégulier qui punit d'une amende les
étrangers en situation irrégulière et
puis le conditionnement de certaines
aides sociales à la résidence régulière
en France pendant 5 ans alors ce
conditionnement il concernera les
allocations familiales le droit au
logement et laallocation personnalisée
d'autonomie mais pas laap hein pas
laallocation personnalisée au logement
elle avait été votée dans le texte au
Parlement mais c'était une mesure qui
avait irrité la majorité présidentielle
et justement les centristes n'ont pas
repris certaines mesures trop dures pour
que ce texte est des chances d'être voté
à l'assemblée et oui ce texte centriste
ne réintroduit pas par exemple la
caution pour les étudiants étrangers le
durcissement du droit du sol ni les
quotas migratoires qui devaient être
votés chaque année par le Parlement
parce que effectivement le but pour
décentriste c'est de faire voter ce
texte immigration au Sénat mais ensuite
de le faire adopter par l'Assemblée
nationale et le problème c'est que les
députés de la majorité présidentielle et
bien ils ont déjà vu le projet de loi
initial du gouvernement validé dans son
intégralité par les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel et donc ils ne veulent
pas revenir avec une nouvelle loi
immigration écoutez à Sylvain Mayard le
patron des députés Renaissance je dit
très clairement la loi immigration est
derrière nous h nous avons voté des
mesures très fortes le cœur de ce que
nous voulions a été voté hein n sur les
27 articles 26 articles ont été votés ce
que nous demandent les Français c'est
pas faire des lois après des loi ce qui
nous demande c'est d'être efficace il
faire en sorte que ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation à être en France repartent de
France et donc le le travail il est au
niveau du gouvernement maintenant au
niveau de nos administrations il faut du
résultat il faut faire en sorte que ça
fonctionne c'est ça que nous demande les
Français n demand pas de faire des lois
pour faire des lois Jean-Michel Arnaud
les députés de la majorité
présidentielle sont contre ce texte
centré s'il y a peu de chance qu'il
passe à l'Assemblée nationale à quoi ça
sert de remettre sur la table ces
mesures d'ord ça sert à faire notre
travail et notre travail consiste à
répondre aux attentes des Français
lorsqu'on regarde dans les enquêtes
d'opinion lorsqu'on est sur le terrain
que sont les attentes des Français il y
a une question liée on en a longuement
parlé sur la question agricole sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat on a la
question de l'éducation on a la question
de la
sécurité souvent lié à la question de
l'immigration je ne fais pas le lien
mais les Français le font et donc le le
conseil constitutionnel a retoqué je
crois 32 articles sur la ainaine
d'articles initialement prévus
essentiellement vous l'aveiez vous-même
dit dans votre exposé parce que un grand
nombre de ces articles ont été
considérés il y a un débat là-dessus
d'ailleurs hein sur le champ de
l'article 45 comme étant des cavaliers
c'est-à-dire sujet hors sujet par
rapport au texte initial entré dans le
processus législatif on emprcte nous
sont triste on ne pas on ne remet pas en
cause euh les choix du Conseil
constitutionnel on est dans un état de
droit on ne crée pas on ne crie pas au
coup d'état constitutionnel on a des
institutionsqu vous le déplorez chacun
est libre de ses propos on les respecte
et le respect aussi des institutions
c'est que le Parlement il légifère et
donc si le gouvernement avait je corrige
un peu les propos de du collègue député
avait accepté un texte de compromis
intégrant un certain nombre d'éléments
qui n'ont pas été considérés comme
receva d'un point de vue procédurial par
le Conseil Constitution nous groupe
centriste on remet simplement en
mouvement les éléments sur lequels le
Conseil constitionnel n'a pas exprimé un
avis sur le fond mais sur la forme et
cet élément- là c'était un élément entre
guillemets de l'accord avec le
gouvernement puisque je le rappelle ce
texte avec les 80 articles 85 si j'ai
bonne mémoire a été voté avec le soutien
du gouvernement et avec un spectre au
niveau de l'Assemblée nationale
évidemment inexistant puisque les
députés n'ont pas pu débattre sur le
fond donc nous ce qu'on propose travers
cette PPL c'est qu'on redébatte du fond
sur les différents sujets qui ont été
abordés lors de ce débat pour répondre
aux besoins des Français vous parlez
d'un accord avec le gouvernement il y en
avait également un autour de la réforme
de l'aide médicale d'État Elisabeth
borne quand elle était premier ministre
elle avait promis au sénateur de droite
et du centre et bien une réforme de
l'Ame qui permet de soigner les
étrangers en situation irrégulière et
Gabriel Atal a dit que cette réforme
aura bien lieu mais par voie
réglementaire et puis uniquement sur la
base d'un rapport qui a été remis au
gouvernement donc c'estàdire qui prévoit
certains ajustements mais pas une
restriction du panier de soins est-ce
que vous avez l'impression d'être
contourné parce que je crois c'est que
si Gabriel Atal qui est un peu dans une
période d'atal Mania voilà c'est c'est
c'est
formidable un jeune dynamique volontaire
je ne ni en rien ces qualités du Premier
ministre ce qu'il faut simplement qu'il
intègre c'est qu'il y ait un parlement
dans ce pays et le Parlement il
représente les territoires
principalement au Sénat et la population
à l'Assemblée nationale et qu'on ne peut
pas gouverner uniquement par voie
réglementaire al c'est un peu technique
mais la loi est fait par le législateur
le règlement il est fait par le
gouvernement et on va pas durant les 2
ans et demi 3 ans qui nous restent actif
pour agir pour le pays travailler
uniquement entre soi entre cabinet
minériel et l'administration sans
consulter et mieux sans écouter sans
coconstruire avec le Parlement et
évidemment le législateur c'est d'abord
le Parlement donc moi je souhaite
effectivement que l'on puisse sur un
certain nombre de sujets avoir une
recherche de compromis de discussion
pour pouvoir coconstruire sur un certain
nombre de sujets répondant aux attentes
exprimé par les Français une réponse
législative et exécutive dernière
question pour conclure on a parlé
pendant des mois de ce sujet de
l'immigration vous le dites il y a
d'autres préoccupations pour les
Français est-ce que l'intention du
gouvernement ce n'est pas justement de
passer à autre chose et d'appliquer la
loi qui a été promulguée oui enfin la
loi qui a été promulguée nous l'avons
soutenu puisque une partie de ce qui a
été retenu par le Constitutionnel a été
soutenu par le Sénat et par une majorité
de parlementaire je comprends qu'il y
est il faut quand même aller plus loin
je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin il
faut surtout écouter les Français et les
Français aujourd'hui ont une
préoccupation principale c'est leur
sécurité et je le dis pas simplement les
Français de droite les Français qui
aussi ont une sensibilité de gauche ce
n'est pas qu'une question de droite ou
de gauche ou du centre c'est une
question nationale et d'intérêt national
parce que les Français ont le sentiment
de ne pas être suffisamment accompagnés
dans la sécurité et ils ont une attente
légitime de sécurité dans leur vie
quotidienne merci Alex à tout à l'heure
tout àheure on parlera notamment des
relations un peu compliqué entre
gabrielal et les républicains après cet
épisode de la loi immigration ce sera
suite dans le club merci Jean-mich merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure